>>> SOY COFFEE WITH LATTE MILK.
>> OOPS, SORRY.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S CRAZY.
NOBODY EVER GETS MY ORDER.
>> ORDER UP!
>> WE'RE GOING TO NEED A BIGGER
CUP!
I'M STEVE.
>> I'M CLAIR.
HI, STEVE.
>> I NEVER DO THIS, BUT -- I WAS
JUST WONDERING IF MAYBE, YOU
WANTED TO GET DINNER SOMETIME?
>> UM -- YEAH.
YEAH, I WOULD -- I WOULD LOVE
THAT.
>> OH, GREAT.
>> OKAY, I'LL SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> YEAH, I CAN'T WAIT.
>> BYE, STEVE.
>> BYE, CLAIR.
>> ANOTHER SOY COFFEE WITH LATTE
MILK.
>> OH, BUT WAIT!
WHERE ARE WE GOING, AND WHAT
TIME, AND WHAT'S YOUR LAST NAME,
AND WHAT'S YOUR PHONE NUMBER,
WHAT'S EVERYTHING?
CLAIR!
>> MOM.
THIS IS A LITTLE NUTS.
BUT I THINK I JUST MET SOMEONE.
>> OH MY GOD!
>> THE GIRL THAT WAS JUST HERE,
DO YOU KNOW HER LAST NAME?
>> NO, DUDE, SORRY.
>> MAYBE THERE'S LIKE THE LAST
NAME ON A RECEIPT THAT YOU COULD
CHECK?
>> DUDE, I'M NOT JUST GOING TO
LIKE SHOW YOU SOMEONE'S RECEIPT.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU MEET YOUR
SOUL MATE, YOU JUST NEED THE
HELP OF A FRIEND?
>> NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪♪
>> 3 MILLION RESULTS?
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN YOU THIS
HAPPY.
YOU ARE GOING TO LOOK AMAZING.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO OUT THERE AND
BE LIKE, SAY WHAT?
HE'S GOING TO BE LIKE, GET ON
IT!
>> HAVE YOU SEEN SOMEBODY NAMED
CLAIR?
HI, IS THIS CLAIR?
THERE'S A SUNSHINE IN HER EYES.
CLAIR?
WELL, YOU'RE CRAZY.
♪♪♪
>> NO.
>> OH!
>> SHE'S LIKE THIS TALL AND SHE
DOESN'T TELL YOU LIKE IMPORTANT
STUFF.
CLAIR!
♪♪♪
>> HE'LL BE HERE SOON.
OKAY.
>> SHE COULD BE AT THE WINE BAR
ON SECOND AVENUE, THE WINE
BAR ON THIRD AVENUE, ANY OF THE
SUBWAY STATIONS --
>> DUDE, IT'S MANHATTAN WITH TWO
Ts, NOT TWO Ds.
>> IT'S NOT MANHADDAN?
>> NO, DUDE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY.
YOU LOOK LIKE SOMEONE --
>> CLAIR!
CLAIR!
>> THANKS.
THIS WAS -- THIS WAS FUN.
>> CLAIR.
CLAIR!
>> STEVE!
>> CLAIR!
OH MY GOD, I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR
YOU ALL NIGHT!
>> OH, REALLY?
WELL -- YOU FOUND ME.
I DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS, BUT --
WOULD YOU WANT TO COME UP?
>> OF COURSE.
I WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> I'LL SEE YOU IN A SEC, THEN.
>> SEE YOU UP THERE.
>> CLAIR, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
APARTMENT YOU'RE IN!
CLAIR!
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]